字幕: Hiroe Nakada
校正: Mai Iida
皆様 初めまして
本日は私が考える 本当の地方の活性化
それを皆様にお伝えしたいと思います
私は秋田県大仙市という所で生まれて
現在25歳です
皆様 秋田はどこにあるかご存知でしょうか
秋田は東京から約650キロも離れている
日本の北部に位置しております
私はそんな秋田で高校まで育ち
都会への憧れから
大学生活と社会人１年目は
神奈川県横浜市で生活していました
秋田育ちの純粋な田舎娘だからこそ
都会に出た私に待っていたのは
全てが驚きの世界でした
そして25年間の人生の中で
一つめのターニングポイントは
この都会で生活していた５年間です
ふと冷静になって社会を見たときに
満員電車の人と
渋谷のスクランブル交差点を道行く人
私はなんで都会にこんなにも
多くの人がいるのだろう
ふとそう思いました
これは秋田の電車の中です
秋田はこんなにのんびりしているんですね
なので私はこの人混みが
想像もつかなかったのです
そしてこの道行く人を見て
この人たちは一体どこに
向かっているのだろう
この人たちを動かしているものは
一体何なのだろう
ふと思いました
そして自分自身も
私は都会で一体何に向かって
生きているのだろう
私は隣の人と同じ方向を向いて
そして同じ事をしている
私は代替のきく存在なのだなと
ふと思う時がありました
そして同時に自分の将来の展望を考え
私は子供が生まれたら
自分が生まれ育った秋田で
子どもを育てたいな
そういう風に考えました
でも いつ秋田に帰るのか
でも 私の大好きな家族が秋田で待っている
だったら帰るのは 今でしょ
そう思い 2012年3月
結婚する予定もないのに秋田に帰りました
ところで皆さん 秋田については
どんな情報を知っていますか
少し私の方からご紹介したいと思います
まずは 秋田は頭が良い子どもが
たくさんいるんです
全国学力テストが１位
そして睡眠時間の摂取量が１位
酒処秋田は お酒を飲むと
眠くなっちゃう人がたくさんいるんですね
そして 佐藤さん伊藤さんの率が１位
そして美容師の人数が１位 面白いでしょう
そして よくニュースでも
目にすると思うんですけども
秋田県は人口減少率がすごく進んでいて
これも47都道府県で1位です
そしてネガティブなんですけども
自殺率も１位
そして一つだけ 子供の人数が47位です
皆さん 感じ取って頂けたでしょうか
秋田は少子高齢化が進み 人口減少も進み
ちょっと危なっかしい地域なのです
そして 私が実際秋田に帰って感じたこと
それはとにかく情報が少ないことです
そして目に見える程人が少ない
だからこそ発信力も弱いんだな
そういうことも感じました
ただ一方で
秋田は無形重要文化財の登録数が
一番多い県でもあるのです
伝統文化がすごく栄えています
そして人の心がとにかく温かいです
秋田県民はおせっかいなほど
面倒見がいいんです
そして 情報が少ない
人が少ない 発信力が弱い
だからこそ私はまだまだ
開拓の余地があると思いました
ここで一つ 秋田の魅力を紹介します
まずは竿燈祭りです
これは秋田市で毎年夏に開かれています
そして今が旬のきりたんぽ おいしそうでしょ
そして私みたいな秋田美人を育ててくれる
秋田のお湯があります
また 私が生まれた大仙市で
とても有名な全国花火大会もあり
重要文化財に登録している
盆踊りもあります
そして秋田美人
まだ秋田の魅力は一部なんですけども
こんなにもたくさんの魅力があるのです
私は この魅力を知れば知るほど
思ったことがあります
それは この魅力をとどめておくのではなくて
もっと日本中 世界中の人に
秋田の魅力に共感してもらおう
そういう風に思いました
そしてこの魅力を外に持ち出すのではなく
地場で感じてもらう
地場だからこそ秋田の魅力
本当の魅力が感じられる
そう思ったのです
そして 私が生まれ育った秋田に
人が来る仕組みづくりをしよう
こう思いました
私は 人が来る仕組づくりにおいて必要なことは
動機ときっかけと興味
そしてオリジナリティに富んでいるもの
これが条件だと考えました
ここから まず私が
秋田についての百科事典になろうと思い
図書館に通い詰めては勉強し
道行く人に話し掛けては
不審者扱いもされるんですけども
とにかく秋田のことを勉強しました
そうして行くうちに
自分が今まで知らなかった
秋田の世界を知ることができたんですね
そして一つ すごい出会いがあったんです
それは 川反芸者
そういう言葉に出逢いました
川反芸者というのは
戦前 60年程前に
秋田の川反という地域で
栄えていた芸者文化です
最盛期の昭和初期には約200人もの
芸者がいたと言われています
秋田には川反という地域は
まだあるんですけども
今の川反はこんな様なんです
閑散としているでしょう
芸者文化があったというのは本当かな
と思うくらいです
そして もう一つ私が
気になっていたキーワード
それは秋田美人というキーワードです
なんで気になっていたかと言うと
私が都会に出て
「水野さんはどこ出身ですか」
「秋田です」
「まあ秋田美人ですね」とよく言われました
だから気になっていたんですね(笑)
ただもう一つ同じ様に
言われていたことがあります
それは「どこに行ったら秋田美人に会えるの」
「そもそも本当にいるの」
私は秋田美人という言葉は
ものすごく抽象的だなと思いました
そこで 私は
川反芸者という伝統文化
そしてそこに込められた想い
そして秋田美人という言葉の
秋田オリジナルのものと
誰も成し得たことがない産業化
これを線で繋ぎ
秋田に人が来る仕組みづくりを
しようと考えました
そして 思いついたのが
「会える秋田美人・あきた舞妓」です
この事業はただ単に
お座敷文化の発達ではなくて
秋田の魅力を 私達特有の色や輝きで彩り
世界中の人へ共感と感動を与える
そういう想いのもと
観光事業の一環として行っております
また 彼女達は
ただ舞妓になりたくて私のもとへ
やってきたのではないのです
自分の手で 自分の口で
秋田の魅力を外に発信したい
そういう想いで私のもとに来てくれました
彼女達の使命は
秋田の魅力を伝える伝道師になることです
そして 彼女達には
あきた舞妓三箇条というものを課しています
一つ 威風凛然
あきた舞妓の名にかけて
内面 外見 意識 知識の美を探求し
品格 奥ゆかしさを持つ 一流の人間となれ
その二 一期一会
すべての出逢いの場がおもてなしの場
秋田の本質と魅力を伝え
最高級のおもてなしを遂行せよ
三つ 温和丁寧
全ての人より考え抜き
接する人の魅力を最大限に察し
先を読み 秋田にとって
相手にとって なくてはならない存在となれ
この三箇条には 己を信じ
ぶれない心とおもてなしの心を持つ
そういう信念が込められています
この事業を通し 私たちは
秋田の伝統、文化、産業の本質を
本来の想いを込めつつも
今の時代に合わせたサービスへと変え
そして伝統文化の継承と
秋田への外貨の落とし込み それを実現させ
秋田の本当の活性化へ繋げる
そういう展望を掲げています
ただ この事業にもここまで来るのには
大変苦労しました
舞妓文化というと
やっぱり皆さんもそうだと思うんですけど
京都が思い出されると思います
色んな方に「京都の舞妓には劣るよね」
そんなことも言われました
ただ この子たちを目の前にすると
皆さんが鼻を伸ばして
「いやあ 美人だね かわいいね」
そうやって言ってくれる様にもなりました
今では行政関連のPR事業にも
ひっぱりだことなってます
ただ 私がやりたいのは最初にお話した様に
秋田に人が来る仕組みづくりです
このあきた舞妓事業は
その想いの一つの切り口でしかありません
私は この切り口から
秋田に根付いている伝統文化
食文化、発酵文化、そして農業の文化
これをまた産業化していきたいと考えています
そして 会社は４月に設立したばかりで
舞妓も８月に実はデビューしたばかりなのです
私がこの事業を通して感じた事
それは 地方の活性化とは
情報が少なく 人が少ないところで
お金をかけて目新しいものを創るのではなく
人の想いが込められた
地域特有のもので魅せていく ということです
その地域にしかないもの
私でしたら秋田 秋田にしかないもの
そこにスポットを当てて 磨き上げていく
私は日本全国にも
そんな「代替の利かない魅力 資源」が
まだまだたくさんあると思っています
今日 私が皆さんに伝えたいのは
それは 人の心は想いによって
動かされるというとこです
身近なアイデアを
想いはそのままに リノベーションする
リノベーションと言っても固く考えないで
今この世に生きている自分が
欲しているものに変化させていく
そして この多様な文化が
入り交じっている時代だからこそ
先人が今まで創り上げてきた伝統文化を
重んじて そして誇りを持って
自分が信じたものへと変化させていく
これが水野千夏流
地方の活性化へ繋がるメッセージです
私は 以上のことが
まだ見ぬみちのく 東北
秋田の魅力発信につながると信じています
さて 秋田美人のみちのくの旅は
まだまだ始まったばかりです
是非皆様も 身近にあるアイデアを掘り起こして
そして日本の本質を世界中へ広げ
みちのくの未来を創っていきましょう
ありがとうございました